did you get recognized law in England a
few times yeah it wasn't too badly
lovely right yeah
so yeah yeah I mean like it's it's it
was weird like the biggest change I know
is this time was that since trash days
you just get recognized of like a [ __ ]
ton more but like I didn't know if like
your audience was in England or like
mostly in Japan
mostly in America and then England
almost in America all right should be me
on that tour in Japan so
I guess so they brought Japan you got
the trashcase mega tour every American
city these guys come it's gonna be fun
the broad Japan was like me in a room
like five pounds a ticket five dollars a
ticket
this is like my hypothetical tool I've
just made it in a high time
[Music]
we're gonna do Journey Across America
yeah
Across America I'd like to I I do I'd
love you know I'd love to travel across
America natsuki and I did have some
plans to do something the year the covid
was a thing yeah unfortunately but uh
he's just too much of a diva now I think
he's driving me mad we want me to join
across Japan I could have killed him
because every like I was like I had heat
stroke really bad and my ear was
exploded it was just a nightmare I'd be
like okay
let's get rolling who's ready and then
about okay Joey natsky and that's kid's
gone just disappeared yeah I need a
toilet and he didn't he just go off and
smoke like a packet of marble cigarettes
every like 10 minutes yeah and he drove
me I had to keep calling him back to be
like all right come on we're gonna film
that's keep having smoking breaks and
then he was like I need a toilet and you
go at one point I watched him walk to
the toilet and just as he restore he'd
like do it and just disappear and he
just driven up the wall British
construction right yeah yeah
but uh yeah no I'd like to go around
America I'll hear your review from your
tour yeah you can tell me which one
would you which hypothetical tour of
Chris it's been me eating Camembert
trying the local cheese of everything
every city trying every cheese in
America I haven't been mukbang on stage
in every city
well since you did like UK content you
think now that the like World's opening
back up you're gonna like do more
outside of Japan now that there's an
actual opportunity to do so yeah
absolutely like I I think it it's not an
exaggeration so I've kind of done
everything in Japan to some extent yeah
this you know there's still a lot of
things I want to do here and I love this
country and I still want to travel it
but yeah I do want to start looking at
doing things outside of Japan more and
the reason another reason I'm building
up to this whole kind of wanted to get
the first ever been before the end of
the year is next year I want to focus on
doing really big crazy physical
challenges had this I I basically up
until June this year I just resigned
myself to the fact that I'm 32 now I'll
probably just be unhealthy for the rest
of my life and then I'll die yeah but uh
and then having this wake-up call and
doing the cycling the Spartan Race and
the boxing all this stuff wait a minute
it doesn't have to be that way it
doesn't have to be a broad in a body bag
any time you see I can turn it around I
can get fit I can stop being Camembert
there is a way out and so you know if
this chest box thing goes smoothly
fingers [ __ ] crossed as much wood
hopefully but I just said bro complete
with my six pack which I'll definitely
have and winning the chess boxing match
and doing the Spartan Race in the cycle
I'll be in a completely different sort
of mindset and fitness level that I can
tackle bigger challenges yeah like
climbing you know Kilimanjaro or Mount
Everest wherever I know
I don't think I'll climb out Everest
yeah people who are physically fit still
do that and die so yeah yeah look at the
v's girl think of the V
I dive at the top of Mount Everest are
too controversial now you can't yeah I
don't want to climb out Everest I'd like
to go to Everest Base Camp I think it'd
be kind of cool just to see them yeah
that'd be cool but I just want to
undertake lots of sort of physical
challenges is and explore the world a
bit more yeah and open up in that regard
and that's what I want to sort of focus
on a lot more next year yeah I'll still
have Japan as my base I think but I'll
be like you know yeah don't do crazy
things yeah I've sailed down the Amazon
in a rubber dinghy the Amazon River or
I'm definitely gonna die I'm gonna die
you said you don't want to be enrolled
in a body bag I think you will be abroad
all I want to do is a trash day special
up Krakatoa I want to climb it to the
top no questions asked let's go practice
but I'm no I'm serious I do want to do
lots of really cool physical stuff that
I never thought yeah I'd be able to do
it sounds weird to hit 32 33 next year
and just sort of accept that I'm just
gonna be unhealthy and not be able to
get up the stairs to suddenly have this
flipping mindset and be like I'm Gonna
Get Fit I'm gonna do everything I didn't
think I could do it's made things a lot
more exciting and give me a sense of
direction that I felt I haven't had the
last sort of eight nine months sounds
like yeah you're like early 30s
Awakening you know I think I do
I didn't want to say that
I didn't want to say that what was your
health results
next year Chris is going to turn up to
the studio in a Porsche licking at my in
my [ __ ] Health Report it was like oh
[ __ ] this is not good yeah it probably
is my mid-life crisis I probably am
going to live to 64 if I'm lucky so I do
want to do all this stuff while I can
while I'm physically fit yeah you never
know what can happen you know you could
hit 40. something could go wrong and you
want me to climb a mountain or whatever
so yeah I want to do it now yeah and
also people keep saying that even though
Gartner and I are the same age Garland
looks 10 years younger so I wanna I
wanna reverse
despite both I think that's just the
Asians
when when I hit like 50 I'm gonna look
like 80. you know that's just how Asian
jeans work when I hit 30 ml like 80.
but uh yeah so that's my that's the
direction I'm sort of heading and I say
yeah that's recommendable I feel yeah no
it's given me a sense of direction I
guess yeah yeah yeah yeah right because
uh you know but during the uh the the
trash day special when we went skiing
together right
[Music]
you know Chris was good he's a good
skier right yeah Chris is being lazy
because he didn't want to do Reds even
though he's very very capable of doing
Reds you just didn't want to put the
work in to do it and we were like we
don't want to do greens all day Chris it
was like Luke's second death skiing ever
and he was still going down Reds in yeah
rolling down yeah it's all going down
if there was like the beginners and then
like not the beginners yeah and then
Christian not the beginners for a day
and we're like we're gonna go down just
Reds at the bottom class rather than
bottom of the top class
yeah because I I remember when we were
filming the special with the trash day
special I was just like on my ass for
half the time and somehow I still made
it down there like First Hill for you
because I looked up and I'm like Chris
is on his ass right now I'm sliding down
what's going on I don't know what
happened that day I don't know if
there's skis or shoes didn't fit but I
did really badly the trash so special
it's like the worst King ever yeah my
legs just were broken right there was
something
ever as well yeah but I'll also tell you
what it was was when you went when you
were going to get you know your skis
your rentals yeah and the woman was like
how much do you weigh and Christmas
lights
just like [ __ ] down
[ __ ] Dallas
that was I was looking forward to the
future
[Music]
but I think the equipment honestly
honest to God I think equipment was the
problem and yeah I didn't want my eyes
those people were lovely yeah
I I you know I failed really badly on
that and I wasn't happy so I mean the
snow is not snow it was slush yeah it
was it was not optimal because you're
underneath for sure yeah it was like we
were skiing down Mr Slurpee yeah because
there was just like halts yeah and if
you fell it was extremely painful oh
yeah oh yeah you definitely hurt
yourself
that was a good trash day special so
that was really weird I remember I you
guys had been driving first or four or
five days at that point yeah right
Yamagata Zao and we met in the really
nice your car and you know I remember
sitting with guns over by the window
talking about the you know something
serious something profound like the
geopolitical situation in Eastern Europe
at the moment and then like no and then
30 minutes later I was watching roll a
[ __ ] snowman like no come on
quicker quicker the dichotomy of trash
taste just watching this like snowman
ridiculous sequence unfold and Jerry
rolling topless in the snow yeah
what is this that is the trash days
experience
it was him unfortunately I was the judge
wasn't it yeah
because mine was like like three times
the size of theirs as well they just
can't roll the little thing and carved
it a little bit of a thing in it I just
might just looked like an Abomination
yeah the most character shall we say
kind of the most like alpha male Snowman
[ __ ] I was like I genuinely felt I
was pushing a boulder trying to push
that we didn't have gloves yeah we
didn't have gloves yeah yeah yeah
exactly our hands are just numb yeah oh
my body was kind of numb as well
yeah what was the I mean snowman aside
what's no matter side what was the
highlight of the trash day special that
one
yeah yeah
I really really enjoyed Hiroshima as
well uh most of that was like just off
camera though
um
experiencing The Nightlife
yeah it was a really Sadie yeah and
definitely Segways on tottori yeah
we both did yeah yeah oh really yeah
yeah unfortunately
but yeah totally the the sand dunes were
like absolutely incredible but like the
city itself was just like right it was
like the most industrial city I've
probably ever been to the Yakitori was
amazing yeah
the thing about the sand dunes is one of
those things where in Japan there's a
lot of things that are oversold yeah
they're amazing I remember I went to the
Grand Japan Canyon in aomori ones and
it's just like a hill that looks [ __ ]
I'm like where's the canyon they're like
this is Canyon I'm like this is [ __ ]
like really clutch clutching a [ __ ]
strong yeah yeah so I was like to
totally sanding it's gonna be like
someone's made a hill out of sand yeah
and you get there and generally
incredible
I've often thought of doing like a short
film there you could make it look like
the Middle East or something if you
frame it right yeah yeah yeah the same
way people were telling us that you
because we weren't allowed to ride the
Segways on the actual sand dunes
apparently they're really strict about
what licenses they give out to the
anything to do with the sandwiches well
it's not allowed to drone either but I
did anyway
I just remember that like you weren't
allowed to do pretty much anything on
the sand dunes yeah you weren't allowed
it's like protected right yeah I don't
understand it it's protected but I don't
I think it would be cool if they let
more activities like
ran and run well yeah I don't really see
why it would be a big issue because like
it was just beautiful sand dunes and
there was nothing you could do on it
even though there was clearly a bunch of
you see it from distance yeah a bunch of
demand for stuff to do on it yeah yeah
you know there's paragliding but you
weren't allowed to go on the center to
take off right before the sand dunes
yeah yeah it was just really weird it
was kind of a shame really because you
felt like you have this amazing thing
and they didn't want to let anyone be
able to like spend a day there yeah like
come drive here then leave after an hour
go to our wonderful City and see the
nothing sure the sugar sometimes you
think oh you wish they were a little
more lenient and kind of opened up to
the idea of maybe letting some cool
activities take place they're run by the
government or run well how was the horse
riding that was really cool they were
really awesome as well yeah the horse
riding was so chill and was so welcoming
I feel like that makes the experience
ten times better yeah yeah exactly and
shut up and you're like we've got film
permission they're like well we still
don't really want you here it's like ah
yeah they're like reluctantly you know
yeah yeah obliged yeah yeah I love
horses yeah yeah horses are great
well who's whose horse was the one that
was like couldn't stop trying to sniff
my horses but that was mine yeah he's
mine mine mine kept trying to overtake
Connors and Joey's on shrooms Joey's one
had just like done a [ __ ] horse you
bastard my voice
that moves yeah so he did yeah so we did
so we did this archery contest and I
remember this as like we I was just like
recently go through the footage
um and for like mostly targets the horse
would walking so slowly that when he he
got in front of the target he just
stopped
it made me look like I was extremely
racist though what because it was like
this giant white horse with this white
man riding on it and it was just like I
could imagine a different time when this
existed this image I was like of course
the white man is on the White Horse
Jesus what do you think of the uh
Stonehenge of Hokkaido better than the
real Stonehenge yeah honestly yeah that
area is actually really cool yeah the
Maui heads yeah the Maui heads the
[ __ ] the Buddha there was actually
like insane that's so cool I was like
definitely the cool spot yeah because we
can have good hotels in Hokkaido no
let's build a Giants of Stonehenge yeah
is really cool though yeah and yeah when
you hit like the gong and you just hear
like the the sound Echo and you hold
down see this thing
yeah yeah yeah it's on a free drink with
my uh my fortune isn't that funny
because they had like a fortune yeah
your fortune told you it's like it says
like free drink at the cafe it's a cafe
yes oh my God so you know when you walk
into the Buddha thing if you just turn
right as you're leaving there's a cafe
and it's this really minimalist Cafe and
then we walked in I remember the woman
was like what the [ __ ] it's like three
foreigners walked in and she's like what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing that's what
the Buddha would have wanted a free
trick yeah I think most random places
went to actually was this German theme
park oh I know it yeah and I've been
there which is which was surprisingly a
lot of fun it was a lot of fun not
because it had anything to do with like
Germany because you couldn't couldn't
even get pretzels there yeah pretzels
yeah you could get pretzels there so
it's obviously like the first hurdle
yeah and the food at the German theme
park was like Ramen and sober and it was
like oh yes I love my German dish sober
yes
it was pretty good though yeah I don't
know yeah then we ended up just like
doing archery and just like okay
run off the road with my go-kart oh this
is Joey yeah you're right on my ass I
kept getting impatient with Chase I kept
ramming my go-kart into the back of
Jerry's go-kart but your card for some
reason was going like way faster and so
I was just having to kept blocking him
off and I almost [ __ ] spawned out
cameraman we had a lot of luck on this
trip you got the best
when I won the horse the nailed it FPS
killed it I got the five-star hotel in
Hiroshima because of that and they had
to sleep in the manga Cafe yeah they
actually like the manga cafes
that was like the 20th time I've ever
done this I'm just like this is just
another hotel for me Joey was like so
excited and we decided I'm just like bro
this place is gonna [ __ ] sauna's
original [ __ ] yeah originally it was
meant to just be like one person who was
staying in the Market Cafe and then we
decided after the challenge that oh no
two people are staying in the Market
Cafe yeah
whatever
[Music]
I thought I thought it'd just be funny
because God's never stated among Cafe
before so I thought this was funny for
the video together
okay okay so yeah it was surprisingly it
was like okay it wasn't like I wouldn't
choose to stay there no right right but
like one thing I did notice is that like
the everything was like leather and like
dark right I do not want to do like a
blue light filter on that [ __ ] place
because because the first thing I
noticed when I sat down I looked at the
PC and there's this link and one of the
most used links was the pornography Tab
and there was just like pages and pages
of pornography right
and so we we do our filming there and
we're going to go to bed and then I hear
someone in the Next Room right and they
they provide headphones to everyone but
it's like the cheapest like the cheapest
slightly not noise canceling yeah not
noise canceling headphones so you can
hear like kind of like Statics you like
and the walls were like paper thin as
well right so you could hear everything
so all I heard was just like static
noise coming from headphone next door uh
and just like oh
and I'm just like
sounds like Connor's favorite holiday
[Laughter]
and I hope you're very faint
and uh I was just like this is this is
my life I [ __ ] hate Connor right now
this is I can't be there from five star
hotel it was more like a three I was
kind of we probably paid yeah so much
money for that we paid so much money at
the hotel and I felt like they mugged us
off a little bit we saved the money on
the manga Cafe
oh did you want to swap Connor you
should have said so because the whole
point of the challenge was that we we
wanted to get the five-star hotel
because it sounds really cool right yeah
yeah and there's only like one in
Hiroshima yeah it's the one above the
station and maybe the Hilton or
something and yeah
no it's a Sheraton yeah it was just
literally like a normal three-star it
cost so much money yeah and it was like
what the [ __ ] one thing I didn't know it
was good good having that as opposed to
yeah one thing I did notice about
staying in the manga hotel is that just
staying in a room with no windows
completely [ __ ] your body clock up so
much because you you wake up and it's
like is it 5 a.m or is it like 11 p.m I
have no [ __ ] movie right now
I remember when because God woke up
first because we were in the rooms next
to each other yeah and we were like all
right we have to go so God like knocks
on my door apparently the first thing he
sees is just me just [ __ ] stumbling
over just like what time is it
like when you're when you wake up in a
pitch black room you're like I have no
idea what time it is
it's just like [ __ ] it's like it looks
like I so wish I [ __ ] filmed it
because it looked like a gremlin just
emerging from his cage it just it just
looks to me what time is it
oh my God
you're right mate
you've been in there for 30 years